Anthony on poursuit on va continuer avec
ce résumé un petit peu de l'actualité
sportive de ces derniers jours et on va
parler à présent du trail by night on en
avait parlé sur ce plateau la semaine
dernière oui Fabien combalusier le le
professeur de PS du du lycée mariecury
nous avait expliqué un peu ce nouveau
concept de de de trail de cour de nuit
c'était dans la forêt de
porsche-fontaine ce weekend près de 200
coureurs ont participé au vertail samedi
soir première course de nuit hein comme
je disais à la lampe frontal organisé
par les élèves c'était l'occasion de
suivre une compétition un peu atypique
imagees d'éodim moine
à quelques minutes du départ du vertreil
de Versailles samedi soir les
participants pour la plupart novice dans
la course de nuit hésite entre
impatience et prudence avant d'avaler 17
km à la lampe frontale c'est évident que
c'est plutôt le jour qu'on qu'on court
mais c'est la première fois que je vais
courir la nuit et ça a l'air plutôt
plutôt attrayant falloir faire attention
aux racines au petits trou et cetera
mais bon on a la frontale donc bon va
voir comment ça se passe on est tous
pareil on va on va se battre on va voir
ce que ça
donne la particularité du vertil est son
départ pendant une vingtaine de minutes
les coureurs ont profité des dernières
lueurs du jour avant de se retrouver
dans le noir total au milieu de la forêt
de porschefontaine à chacun sa tactique
l'AMPE allumé dès le début pour certains
d'autres la conservent pour l'entrée des
bois autant dire qu'il fallait faire
attention où l'on mettait les
pied forcément on court un peu moins
vite surtout dans les descentes les
choses comme ça on est un peu plus
vigilant au caillou mais bon ça devrait
aller autre exercice de la course de
nuit le passage de relais il secourait
aussi en équipe et dans le noir passer
le témoin à son coéquipier n'est pas
chose aisée cette course inédite était
organisée par 35 élèves du lycée
marieerry de Versailles dans le cadre de
leur enseignement d'exploration contrat
rempli donc pour cette première édition
près de 200 participants ont tenté
l'aventure et avec le froid il fallait
être courageux en plus he pour faire ce
trail de nuit du côté de versaill on
continue à présent avec les autres
résultats sport en bref du football tout
d'abord les les trib tribun du stade de
la cou Montini sont restés désespérément
vides he ce ce weekend lors de cette 10e
journée les féminines devaient recevoir
Épinal dans un dans un duel de mal
classé mais le manteau blanc a empêché
les les Jos vogiennes de prendre la
route pour pour Montini les inimontaines
restent donc 7e de Division 2 avec 18
points on continue toujours football
chez les hommes chez les hommes en péage
Promotion d'Honneur trappe s'est
écroulée à jouilmoutier défaite 4 buts à
un les traapistes tombent à la 7e place
dans dans une poule où tout est très
serré les les h premiers se tiennent en
8 points le Trapp va devoir vite relever
la tête si s'ils ne veulent pas voir la
zone de relégation arrivver et dans la
pousé toujours promotion Promotion
d'Honneur le SG en cours s'est imposé
sur sa pelouse face à Tremblet sur le
score de 3 buts à 2 et prend même du
coup la tête de la poule de pH avec
égalité de points avec l'Entente sportif
parisienne mais avec une meilleure
différence de but et après le football
le basket et cette surprise qu'on
attendait pas il y a eu un événement ce
weekend Wilfried je veux bien sûr parler
de l'Entente le CH versa et on a
l'habitude des victoires plutôt
écrasantes et bien c ce weekend lors de
cette 10e journée les féminines de le
LCV ont perdu tout simplement difficile
pour le moral de
perdès victoire consécutiv ça va être
très difficile elles ont elles se sont
incliné face à trègux 61 à 60 donc fin
de série évidemment après neu victoires
consécutives en championnat mais pas de
panique les joueus de de vino Bardic
restent leader solid leader de National
2 et on termine avec le hand à présent
toujours chez les féminines les
féminines on parle beaucoup femme
aujourd'hui les féminines de Montini se
sont incliné sur le parquet de de
Villemomble 32 buts à 22 les joueus de
Stéphane paysan restent 8e de National 2
avec 4 points d'avance sur le premier
relégable merci Antony c'est la fin de
cette page sport on vous retrouve lundi
prochain aux mêmes horaires le 78 de ce
3 décembre est presque terminé lui aussi
juste le temps de revenir sur la
principale information du jour dont nous
parlions au début de cette édition
l'inauguration de la Faculté des
sciences de la santé à 5 ans en Yveline
à Montini le Bretonneux en présence de
la ministre de la Santé Marie sol Touren
mais aussi de de Simon veille qui donne
d'ailleurs son nom à cet équipement une
faculté qui doit bien évidemment assurer
un rôle de formation mais surtout
répondre à plusieurs genux dont celui
des déserts
médicaux ces apparitions se font de plus
en plus rares mais Simone veille
ancienne ministre de la Santé celle qui
a défendu et obtenu le droit à
l'avortement a tenu à être présente pour
l'inauguration de l'UFR des Sciences de
la Santé de Montini qui porte dorénavant
son nom une UFR des sciences de la santé
autrement dit une université où l'on
enseigne à la soit le médical et le
paramédical première particularité la
seconde cet UFR est implanté dans la
ville et non au sein d'un établissement
hospitalier universitaire comme cela se
voit couramment et ce n'est pas un
hasard on pense que ça ça permet pour
partie de résoudre et de
traiter les difficultés que l'on a à
former des professions de santé on pense
peut-être faire soit des maisons de
santé universitaires soit des des pôles
de santé qui qui vont être des des
endroits de de soins de premier recours
et qui permettraiit peut-être de
désengorger un petit peu les urgences
des hôpitaux et puis de prendre en
charge de
façon très universitaire je dirais des
malades si tous les étudiants sont
formés en centre-eville si tous les
étudiants passent l'ensemble de leur
cursus universitaire à l'intérieur de
l'hôpital il y a peu de chance pour
qu'ils aient envie d'aller s'installer à
l'extérieur de l'hôpital et encore moins
à l'extérieur des grandes villes donc
c'est évidemment un enjeu tout à fait
important rapprocher la formation des
lieux d'installation à venir la lutte
contre les déserts médicaux la ministre
présentera prochainement des mesures
dans ce sens autre application de l'UFR
des Sciences de la Santé qui a convaincu
marietouren la mutualisation des moyens
entre différentes disciplines dans ce
laboratoire par exemple les chercheurs
traitent des pathologies liées à des
traumatismes de la moelle osseuse de la
recherche fondamental avec des buts
appliqués au quotidien quand la la
personne a eu un accident de voiture ou
a subi une atteinte au niveau du système
nerveux central ça a des conséquences
sur sa sexualité et sa continence donc
on travaille sur des modèles animaux de
façon à comprendre et à palier
éventuellement dans l'avenir ces
troubles particuliers en trouvant des
médicaments qui pourraient agir sur la
relaxation de de la de la Vess d'une
part ou en interrogeant plus précisément
le système nerveux central de façon à
faire des thérapies novatrices et en
particulier thérapies à base de
transfert de Gunes l'UFR des Sciences de
la Santé avait été pensé dès 2003 il est
situé à deux pas du centre commercial
régional accueille 1000 étudiants
première année et 5000 en totalité les
enfis sont plus adaptés c'est
exclusivement des cours de M je pense
contrairement à l'ancienne fac après moi
je la trouve un peu moins chaleureuse
c'est plus austère ben elle est très
sympa euh elle est plus proche de la
gare donc c'est plus rapide donc c'est
pratique en tout cette UFR compte 125
enseignants et 18 laboratoires
mixtes une dernière information elle
concerne notre Dame des land ce n'est
pas dans les yelin cette ville qui doit
accueillir un aéroport majeur dans les
prochaines années l'opposition vous le
savez sans doute est forte sur place
avec des affrontements ces derniers
jours et bien un collectif sur 50 ans en
Eveline a décidé lui aussi de rentrer en
résistance c'est lui qui le dit qu'
l'écrit dans son communiqué de presse le
collectif de C50 ans en Yveline contre
l'aéroport Notre Dame des Landes qui
vient de voir le jour et dénonce coût du
projet et atteinte à l'environnement
prochain rendez-vous avec l'info sur
TVfil 78 c'est à 20h et à 22h l'actu le
tout image de la rédaction je vous
retrouve demain 18h avec de nouveaux
invités en direct et puis à 19h pour la
première rediffusion excellente soirée
sur té
[Musique]
fil